c'est une manifestation pour nous qui
nous sert de tremplin pour revenir dans
la ville de rodez avec un spectacle que
nous allons offrir
et puis c'est un point important pour
notre championnat puisque nous sommes à
la 7ème journée et les choses deviennent
très très sérieuse pour le titre final
donc tous les ingrédients sont là pour
nous permettre d'organiser une très
belle fête
non seulement une porte compétition qui
va être très belle sous l'eau mais
également tout un bon spectacle nous
mettons tour avec un village avec des
exposants avec des jeux pour les enfants
de cerfs-volants c'est qu'une grand
concert en live sur le podium aurait
donc tout est mis en place et la baie du
robert mme sicuro très bien et là nous
avons trouvé un très bon appui de la
ville is seulement pour nous aider à
organiser à fêter les 40 ans du fr 1
avant tout les yoles dans la ville du
rohmer un avant tout un avant-goût de
l'étape puisqu'on aura une étape
justement de
du tout qui va arriver dans cette ville
et puis pour nous également de commencer
à nous rôder sur la partie animation lié
l'animation à la compétition puisque
prenant le trouble en batik ces huit
jours d'organisation de ce type que nous
avons avec un très large public et nous
ne doutons pas qu'il sera très nombreux
dimanche qu'on voit les hommes évoluent
dans la baie de robert l'enjeu de la
compétition c'est en connaissant il ya
un point d'écart entre le premier
second cela aussi roland ces zones de
l'intérêt à l'épreuve absolument non
seul moyen pour l'écart entre le premier
et le
deuxième mais entre le troisième et le
sixième
il ya à peine six ou sept points d'écart
et là les choses vont être les arbres
parce que tout le monde veut tout le
podium et tout le monde veut gagner donc
la compétition va être très belle et
nous sommes certains d'avoir deux très
belles courses une à deux voiles qui va
à partir de 22h45 et une deuxième une
heure après l'arrivée de la première
yonne sans tout dévoiler les grandes
lignes du tout que vous envisagez le
concept communication l'écosystème
digital la génération sont plus que
jamais en reste propriétaire de ces
images de l'organisation de la manière
des regards pour avancer le projet
absolument absolument notre nom et puis
et nous tenons également je le précise
notamment également à montrer notre
fidélité à notre partenaire martin qui
dès le début est avec nous et fait du
direct dans courrier diffusé de
directeur c'est déjà important et nous
voulons que tous ceux qui font des
images à droite à gauche ne puisse pas
en diffuser comme cela il ya un respect
du travail qui est fait et puis
nous avons mis en place un certain
nombre de choses avec toute cette
plateforme digitale pouvait mettre à
tout à chacun de découvrir jeu somme à
la manifestation de la ville et puis
d'échanger également avec nous donc
c'est toute cette nouvelle plateforme
que nous avons présentés aujourd'hui qui
va permettre à tous chacun bien de vivre
à laguiole à sa façon